good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
tuesday hope everyone's having an
amazing week so far
jack and i are so excited to be here in
studio wearing our new merch collection
which drops tomorrow i am wearing the
set in teal
i'm wearing an extra large this one has
pockets it's everything of the sort
yesterday i also wore black and extra
large
yes yesterday i wore the teal size
medium in both and once again i think i
could have stood to size down in the
pants which is always a great feeling
today i am wearing the pink sweater
which i don't think you guys have seen
yet
size medium i styled it like with a
little colored shirt underneath okay so
i have this one collared shirt
and it's actually a dress and so every
time i wear it under my sweatshirt i
have to like bunch it up
and it gives me so much extra material
material
and extra looking miss
and today i just like couldn't deal with
it with looking like so extra
and i got out my scissors and i cut the
shirt i literally
cut the shirt up too and so now i just
have this perfect little because you
probably mostly wear it only as a collar
never worn it as a dress it went to my
knees when i would wear a skirt it would
come out the bottom
l oh so i took matters into my own hands
i cut the shirt also last week i
promised you guys that i would
start showing some leg and i delivered
oh my god my legs are here
they're very sexy and tan tan looks like
i use tamlox on
saturday night and it's carried me
through even though i've showered and
bathed like
six times since then i think i have a
nice little glow about me i've decided
to treat myself um later this week and
get myself a spray tan
if you want to do like two for one it's
a better price like if you want oh my
god that would be so amazing but i'm
going on the retreat night i would just
sweat it all and you got to be natural
oh naturally at the retreat yes except i
am going to get my eyebrows dyed for the
retreat it's not going to be a natural
galley so i don't have oh my god into
the streets and i don't be like
i dye my eyebrows i dye my hair
um also dropping in this merch
collection we have our mugs if you want
to take a look on here
and then also be phone cases in three
different colors and every variety
possible
for your phone so don't worry about the
size we carry all sizes because we are
size inclusive we'd love to see it we
also have a teal
phone case this this collection is just
like my favorite ever we are 100 100
percent
we are harmer huh and the vibes are so
plenty they're going to take you
right into spring and i'm just so
excited that it's out we actually pushed
it up a little bit because we had like
we couldn't yes it was supposed to be
like literally in a month
we couldn't stand to wait any longer so
i hope you guys are as excited as we are
drops tomorrow morning 10 a.m
shop morning toast.com also we have a
hat that is just like
going to change all day yesterday it's
so cool i wore it the other day and
someone was like you look like a
celebrity and i was like
dad hats are like oh i'm so famous like
incognito please don't look at me
paparazzi stop like i can't no i'm not
dating johnny depp
like maybe we are you know um yes
i'm having a really hard time focusing i
know there's something that you want to
get off your chest
no there isn't like i really like don't
even want to talk about it but like it's
about it's eating me up inside and like
and so i think you should talk about it
i hate to even like and i know people
are gonna think i'm kidding like i'm
dead [ __ ] serious like
i hate to even like bring up like some
of the dark times but like it's
bothering me so much
like i just i need to talk about it okay
please talk about it and
take us from the beginning yeah i mean i
don't know if you're new here if you've
been along for the crazy journey that's
been the last three years but everyone
knows like and i talked about it at the
end of our episode
of 2020. like some of my biggest regrets
for the year 2020.
and i always stand by like one of my
biggest regrets was like that incredibly
stupid thing i said about one tree hill
i'm like
before i even dive into it i just need
to make it known like i do not stand by
that statement it was one of the worst
things i ever typed and i can't believe
like i'm so i'm so disappointed in
myself like i just want to
say that first and it's probably like
one of those things that like haunts me
the most like when i think about like
why was i even thinking that way and of
course i was talking about a tv show
but like i i just didn't like what i
said and basically
what i had said was there was a
character named peyton who
like had a 24-hour camera in her bedroom
and then ended up with a stalker
and my instagram story was like just
like victim blaming like well of course
like she
of course like this guy got into her
house like why did she have a camera
idiot like i was just being insane like
it was a terrible
thing to say and now i never even
finished watching one true hill even
though i liked it so much
because like the trauma that i had to
deal with like i'm dead serious like
i can't when people talk about it like i
literally shudder like i i can't
so of course like i got unbelievably
canceled when i did that instagram story
like
i apologized immediately and like i
really understood why i said
why what i said was wrong um but like
buzzfeed wrote it up it became this huge
thing like
and people were rightfully like very
upset with me like pitchforks
they were coming for me and i've kind of
like made peace with
no i've not made peace but i've really
forgotten about it like i push it out of
my memory
but this morning somebody sent me
something that like
shook my [ __ ] me to my core
and i didn't even want to talk about it
but like i just i feel like i need to so
if
i may please buzzfeed
yeah wrote an article one hour ago
titled 26 wild things i forgot
actually happened in the one tree hill
pilot
number 26 number 26
okay one final note trigger warning
sexual sexual assault why was payton
allowed to have a webcam that just
recorded her in her room 24 7 for the
whole world to see
the poor girl had practically no
supervision no wonder
derek showed up so easily in season four
which is more or less what i said mine
was like a little harsher i don't want
to call her like an idiot cause i'm an
animal but but
literally like the same concept yes and
i'm just like
and people like were really upset with
me and rightfully so because like i have
such a big platform
and like i was saying something so
offensive yeah but now they need to they
what's a bigger platform than buzzfeed
and let's see
my platform has been like dying in
relevancy for the last 10 years like we
all [ __ ] know that like
this is an actual like influential news
outlet platform
and i just like not that i'm pro
canceled culture but like i where's that
energy you need to channel that same
energy towards buzzfeed today yeah it
just like bothered me so much like it's
literally oh almost verbatim what i said
yeah mine was again like harsher but
it just i couldn't believe it it's also
the irony it's not just like any
publication it said pretty much the same
thing that they cancelled you for but
like
it's the publication that wrote up what
i did right so
it was just like bothering me so much
and like this is literally what i wrote
my book
available on amazon girl don't drop the
crazy beautiful life of an instagram
thirst monster in case this goes viral
you know
um your shops farm patreon.com
the morning toast um
no no like literally when i wrote my
book it's like cancellations aren't
one-size-fits-all like people get away
with things and then other people don't
and it's like where's the energy
where's the energy where is the
consistent energy we see consistency
i really just wanted to bring that up
i'm really sorry like if it's
like it's triggering me to talk about it
and i'm sure it's triggering to other
people because that was like such a dark
time for our community just the
hypocrisy like you just gotta call it
out i just
i it you know me like i cannot let
anything go and like i hold on to
grudges for so long like
this i just couldn't let it go and i'm
sorry to even like you know yuck our
yums on today's beautiful tuesday
morning show but
i just i felt as though like i really
needed to bring that up like where's the
energy
yeah well we'll see we'll look out for
it it was only
published two hours ago okay so you feel
better you got that off your chest i do
okay now i'm like should i have even
said anything but i feel fine yeah no
you're just
stating the facts i'm just stating how i
feel like this is literally my podcast
if you don't like it you can leave
where we talk about how we feel yeah no
it's literally called the morning
feeling
and this is how i feel yeah okay well
i'm glad that you got that off your
chest now we can
move forward with this beautiful tuesday
which is a fabulous wonderful day for
sure
but a few things are missing what theo
theo he's at the spa
two days of work yesterday rained and
today
he's at the spa like sorry theo's
literally so [ __ ] busy yeah and
booked
speaking of the spa bruno is also going
to the spa today and he's
just like so excited but this morning so
he comes into bed with me i actually
have been switching up my morning
routine i told you i was going to do it
and i've been doing it and things have
been different for me oh
so usually i set my alarm like 30
minutes before i need to get up and i
i think that it takes me 30 minutes to
wake up and just lose
but then i realized that on the weekends
i wake up oh yeah you told me like
pretty much at the exact same time that
i need to get up for work so i'm like
what if i just didn't set an alarm maybe
i would wake up on my own right so now
i've started setting my alarm for the
absolute last time i can get out of bed
right the latest possible
and i've been waking up before before at
the 30 minute
time so i must have been having my alarm
set go off like five minutes my friend
cycle ended and i was waking up so tired
so it's been amazing i got these 30
minute
extra minutes in bed and you're living
technically like alarm free living
i'm technically living alarm free living
i get 30 extra minutes in bed
with bruno because that's when he comes
back from his morning business
this morning he was chewing chewing
chewing for 30 minutes i just assumed it
was a billy stick
yeah by the time i woke up wait let me
guess like a makeup brush
i know it works it was like my blistex
chapstick my medicated lip ointment so
he got into the lip appointment he must
have decided like he didn't like
containers because it literally tastes
like
you know icy hot yeah lidocaine he was
chewing the cap like down to a pulp he
was chewing for
25 30 minutes wow so i was like really
worried about it
all morning just like looking at him
like are you okay luckily i googled it
and someone else had the exact same
experience he has eaten my aquaphor and
visine which is really bad and he was
totally fine
and so yes he might have um diary or
vomiting later today but i was just
excited for looking at him all morning
like
are you okay no literally dogs are so
crazy they're so
crazy and so just my thoughts are with
bru this morning i hope when i get home
like he's still okay godspeed to burr we
are all thinking of him but it also
wasn't the first time he got into this
particular chapstick the last time he
didn't get 30 minutes with it he maybe
got like five so oh my god he's like a
young boy who's getting into his mom's
makeup right it's so cute he built up
his tolerance for the appointment a few
months ago so i think that this time
he'll be okay maybe he gets like high
off the lidocaine he's just like looking
for a fix
i think that he's just looking for a
fixed period yeah
um i actually spent the evening catching
up on like tv i literally haven't
watched in so long so i caught up
i saw like eight more episodes of blue
bloods and it's just like such a feel
good show i just absolutely love it
and i also caught up on rupaul's drag
race which now i know your story how did
the polls go i voted
for who i voted for got mick and then i
voted for rose
why just because of what i said they no
just like based on your recaps
yeah that's where i saw it going well
i've just been having a really hard time
with this contestant rose because like
when they gave their nobody went home
this week so
two weeks is the finale so they just
kind of like did a wrap-up episode and
roo and the judges were just like saying
something nice to everyone and
what they said about rose was basically
like you've just been so professional
this whole season and like you're you
come
hard to work you memorize your lines and
i couldn't figure out like
what it is about rose that like just
doesn't make her a winner and i was
talking to kristin
um our friend kristen because she
actually watches her pulse drag race and
she was just like
rose has no spark like and that's
exactly what it is x factor
it's the x factor like but she's easily
the most talented in comedy
in dancing and singing and acting in in
everything except for makeup like kind
of sucks
from the other girl so it's like what is
it like why is she like so obviously not
the winner when she's like better than
everyone
and kristen like nailed it like she's no
spark like there's nothing like jenna
it's that you out of eve like there's no
shot of eve there so
now based on my polls people are pretty
much saying they think there's like
gonna be two winners
one time at all stars there was two
winners but
the it's not famously it's not rupaul's
best friend's race it's rupaul's drag
race and there's one winner
i think that there should be one winner
i'll be disappointed there's two winners
but based on like what you said i just
don't see it going
that way no i really um i think it's
going to be gottmick and based on this
last episode like rue
i was literally hysterically crying the
last episode before the finale are you
talking to in that
comic because gottmake is trans and i
believe
that gottmack is one of the first trans
contestants i know there was a trans
contestant who came out at a reunion
but i do believe comic is the first
contestant to go through the entire
um show as an openly trans person
and god make is just like really like
like
this is what ruse said like setting the
road map for trans kids who like just
don't
see themselves represented in modern
like
television and rude just got like all
choked up because and the last episode
before the finale is always really
emotional
they like talk to their younger selves
it's like really sweet and
gottmix was just like so emotional like
i was literally hysterically crying like
so was ruined like rude does not cry and
like rude doesn't even like talk like
he's just like so serious and it was
really like a beautiful moment and
that's why i really feel like gomick
deserves to win one just like based on
her work thus far
but also comics deserves to win because
of like the message that it sends you
know
so my money's on got mike even though
everyone's like really pulling for
simone and i've just like really kind of
fell off the simone
bandwagon in the last few weeks we've
heard about it so we'll see
the finale's not for two weeks and
there's rumors that they are going to do
the
there's rumors there's rupolmers that
they're
they are going to do the live finale
they always do it live
at a ballroom at a ballroom actually
it's at the ace sitter hotel where i
actually performed
in l.a and there are rumors swirling
people have like you know putting some
like easter eggs together from different
queens from different seasons that have
been in la like
they think in two weeks like obviously
not with an audience but they think we
might have a
i think that i think that you could as
well i think that you could too and you
should and you should because it sounds
like it's been a great season
it's actually big deserve a great finale
it's been i think one of the best
seasons like in so long like i feel like
i really can't decide
if any one of the final four one like
even candy mews like i would be so happy
so it's really like been such a good
season
and may the best drag queen win
love it well that's exciting that you
watched some good tv i did not turn my
tv on last night
i finally finished this book that i had
been reading i saw and instagram
it's a really really crazy true story
and it's like about this woman who you
probably have never heard of though she
was at like all of the big events like
in napoleon's life and then her
and her husband went on to be the king
of king and queen of sweden which was
just like kind of random
they were like literally french people
and then
some swedish officials were like we want
you to be the king queen you have a good
relationship with napoleon
everyone would just like say that to me
like i would love you to be the king and
queen of my land
a hundred percent but then when you like
that's the best part about these um
history books or shows it's like when
you get to the end when it's like the
the text on screen
yeah where it tells you like what wound
up happening and the fact that these two
who were like the sort of
random king and queen of sweden still
have descendants on the throne today
right and it's just an amazing story
called the queen's fortune and i
recommend it to those who are into
historical fiction and definitely lagged
at times but
i'm so glad that i know the story one
which i would have never heard then i
also started a new book because i still
didn't want to turn on my tv because it
was like 10 o'clock and i actually think
it's a book that you might like
you know i was hoping that you would
like it and then recommend it to me
because i just can't choose my own books
like
i just like to be recommended by someone
so far you would like it but it
definitely has like
a spooky weirdness to it and i don't
know what that's going to be yet i'm
reading the hunting lives by may cobb
which
spooky weirdness it also hasn't come out
yet but it was a book of the month book
so if you do book of the month
you you could have selected it but it
comes out like next week cool
i just got like an advanced thank you oh
my god
she's such a book of influencers
dead oh my god neck alley like when my
book i do netgalley a lot because um
i have a profile and and so i request
and you are like an influential person
in the literary space 100
sometimes i get the books that i want
sometimes i get denied no hard feelings
and but then it's like i don't want to
read it yet because it's not in the
conversation
you can't talk to literally anyone about
it so i literally don't even read them
until they come out when it's so neck
ellie's like a platform where people can
sign up to get like advanced copies of
certain books yes
and part of the publishing process is
like you actually are supposed to give
out a few copies
to random people um and so i remember i
got like a message from someone like i
just read your book and i like was
freaking out i'm like
i caught my pokemon someone got my book
and she was like it's totally fine it's
netgalley and some of the reviews from
netgalley were really mean
oh i mean but it's like also that's not
your target it's not my dead audience
yes
so no net galley's uh pretty cool and
i'm reading a netgalley book yeah don't
listen to next i'm a netgalley girlie
you're a netgalley girly girljob.combook
love to see you at patreon.com and
instagram.com forward slash pops with no
job forward slash jackie your problems
forward slash
with no job there was a reason oh my god
there's been a rebirth i totally forgot
how is it going by the way
sensational i've never looked back i've
never thought twice about it yes i feel
so [ __ ] good about it i
wish i did it sooner that is the best
like making hasty decisions and like
feeling so confident in them i'm so
happy for you i smile every time i
remember
that there's been a rebrand delightful
well without
further ado well he's not here but
it's [ __ ] sad and his absences fell
but without further ado
to do it is time for the fast side
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
noom think about everything you've ever
learned about getting healthy
there's a lot of contradictory
information out there and things like
the old-fashioned food pyramid aren't
much help
enter noom why noob because it's not
about what you just ate but about how
you eat in general
noom will teach you about eating
cravings and how to build new habits
so you can ditch your misconceptions and
get smart about food and the choices you
make
pneuma is based in psychology so noon
will teach you how to eat so you can
accomplish your personal health goals
and stick with them long term because
you don't need rules to lose weight you
need
knowledge so nume is uh has a cognitive
behavioral approach which means you're
not just losing weight but you're
building the habits you need to keep it
off
and jackie has been like i don't know
it's been like almost a year now since
you started using noob
more than a year i think and tell us a
little bit about your journey
oh i love newm it's like it's the
accountability coach that we are right
and not only do they have people that
you can talk to if you want to get like
advice or just like nutritional
educational information
they also have a database of food where
you plug in what you've eaten
and it's like one of the most accurate
in the world yeah and extensive like
they have all these random foods that i
eat that like you would think that they
don't have and it helps you track your
calories and also like track
how much fat carbs protein macros and
it's a wonderful platform if you are
looking to make a change in your life
it's a
fabulous place to start it's really the
only place to start
right and i i've loved my life with noon
noom is forgiving because you're human
so if you go off track you can just get
back on track tomorrow
and they don't demand much of your time
only 10 minutes a day there's a science
to getting healthier and it's called
noom
sign up for your trial today at
noomnoom.com
toast learn how to eat again with noom
sign up for your trial today at
noomnoom.com
toast again that's noom.com toast
n-o-o-m okay let's get
into the news first up a little vaccine
news
uh the u.s will temporarily halt the use
of the johnson johnson
coven 19 vaccine this is um no bueno
this is crazy i know i'm like quaking
for everyone who got johnson johnson
already
federal health agencies will temporarily
stop using johnson johnson's one dose
vaccine after six women developed blood
clots
including one who died according to
officials and a new report
tuesday the fda announced the pause
saying there have been half a dozen
reports of rare and severe type of blood
clot
in patients who received the vaccine the
clots were
observed along with reduced platelet
counts making the usual treatment for
blood clots the blood thinner
heparin potentially dangerous
right now these adverse events appear to
be extremely rare
the cdc tweeted those affected were six
women between the ages of eighteen and
forty eight who developed the question
that's like legit us that's our audience
which is i felt it was important too
the story they're saying that people who
receive the j j vaccine who are
experiencing severe headache abdominal
pain
leg pain or shortness of breath within
three weeks of receiving the job
are advised to contact their health care
provider the feds hope the pause will
serve as a strong signal to the states
to do the same so i guess it's up to
each state to decide if they want to
continue with it
but it could also be up to people like
you can choose to get the johnson
johnson one and i think for the most
part like
the general consensus has been like
moderna and pfizer are like
better than johnson johnson in terms of
the efficacy yes but also in terms of
the technology used to create the
vaccine so the johnson johnson vaccine
is like the old model of vaccination
whereas modern advisor are like the new
tech well it's new technology
that's been around for that they've been
studying for a while it's this mrna
um so that's maybe that's why it's
called moderna
because it's modern i.e mrna modern
rna oh maybe um like honestly
johnson and johnson like make shampoo
and so you think they should stick to it
no i'm just saying like when it comes to
choosing which vaccine someone should
get like
i'm always inclined to go with the
company that makes medicine
versus the one that makes baby shampoo
johnson and johnson is a major
pharmaceutical company
yes whatever not not to me they ain't
whatever happened to astrazeneca well
astro seneca was never really available
in the us but it was
available abroad in europe and they also
paused for a while i just want to say
like
if you work in big pharma like your
margin for error like
really can't exist um and so although
yes it is only six people
one person [ __ ] died and this is just
like unacceptable in my eyes
yeah and like okay so the vaccine took
so [ __ ] long like we were literally
all quarantined for a year
because fda had to approve it had to be
perfect and like literally we're having
these problems
yes so what was the whole year we
[ __ ] waited for just so you know in
terms of vaccines
development it didn't take so [ __ ]
long uh in terms of me sitting on my ass
in my house like not able to see the
light of day it took a long time
yes i i hear you i'm just saying like
for me for you but not for me
no but so yes you're right very smart
too report on this story so if you
uh haven't gotten vaccinated yet i would
maybe go for madonna or pfizer
well you might not have a choice and
also if you have gotten jj just
keep your keep listen to your body
listen to your body and
uh talk to a doctor today if you're
experiencing those symptoms that we
mentioned
yes are you ready for our next story
sure that just
came out right after we wrap yesterday's
episode which is to show you that we had
not seen the trailer when it dropped at
11 30 a.m yesterday when we started
recording at 10 30 a.m when we
opened our episode talking about two
truths and a lie and the real housewives
of beverly hills trailer opened talking
about
two truths it was just a mere
coincidence and kind of like a
telepathic moment
between a couple of you know coastal
icons yes and it's one of those things
where it's like
coincidences like my coincidence
list yes oh like hurricane harvey at the
same time harvey weinstein
jimmy kimmel the two snow whites
the two cinderellas at the same time yes
the two steve jobs movies
yes exactly and now two truths and a lie
literally so the real housewives beverly
hills season 11 trailer is
more dramatic than we ever expected
reports e news and honestly i totally
agree agreed the jaw-dropping season 11
first trailer real housewives of beverly
hills just released
footage to e news and it puts the
veterans
kyle lee serena erica jane dory kemsley
garcelle and sutton who's an official
housewife now
back in the spotlight and their baggage
too the new season also welcomes new
housewife
crystal kung minkoff plus kathy hilton
who will serve as a friend of the ladies
in the trailer erica's grill by her
co-stars about her divorce from her
strange husband tom gerardi
and his ongoing legal woes okay they did
not
hold back no there was they literally
went to turning stone casino because
they did not leave one stone unturned
it seems like everything we've been
wondering like are they going to address
they do address like of course the time
derarity of it all
not only does it look like they address
it looks like it's like a major topic of
conversation for the entire season
yes we were curious if like the amelia
hamlin scott disick of it all would be
addressed and it was
scott's literally i mean kyle richards
is literally saying like he's too old
for her and he has three kids i know but
she said it like with a smile and a
laugh which makes me feel like they're
not like taking
me seriously it's seriously and no one's
they're actually happy that's not really
in heaven lisa and is in heaven kyle is
best friends with chris
like she would never talk poorly about
scott nor should she
and i just i don't want to hear about
scott and emilia if it's in any sort of
like
celebratory way yes i completely agree
we got
um crystal and kathy hilton who both
look like they're bringing
different but important energies crystal
looks like she's bringing a lot of drama
like literally telling
sutton that she's jealous of her and
that she's a miserable obnoxious person
hilarious
kathy looks like she's bringing a lot of
wealth because they're like building
this home that's 53 million dollars
and that got us talking about kathy
hilton's finances like of course she's a
wealthy woman but um
i don't know if she's like 53 million
dollar house in la wealthy
yeah i don't know i'm sure we'll find
out we also were thinking like maybe
she's a
realtor and she's just like showing a
home or something and they're just like
looking at this big ass home
i feel like that's it yeah i feel i feel
like that's possible but i do think
she'll bring
so much to the show elegance well
before i saw the trailer i wasn't like
so excited about her joining i didn't
really feel one way or the other but
after the trailer i'm like oh she's
going to be a great addition
it does look like sutton's track is
getting walked all over in the trailer
and i already feel so badly for her
because she has like a really
interesting personality where she like
says
wild outlandish things and like it's
kind of like [ __ ] which we love but
she doesn't have like a strong backbone
to defend those yeah she's just like
extremely sensitive
yeah so i i felt bad for her when
literally erica talks to her like this
[ __ ] that's literally what she said but
i also
i mean or what i'll wait to see how it
all
plays out but based on what i saw in the
trailer yeah me too
i just feel like i might be a turning
stone as well and on erica
you know we have to see what she says
because at the end of the day like the
allegations against her and tom are like
really [ __ ] serious like taking um
settlement money away from like orphans
and widows who like that's what derek
said like
who really need it so it's like actually
really serious and so i hope they dive
into it more than just like
oh i can't talk about this legal ongoing
ongoing legal situation i hate that
i feel like it's going to be so much of
that and it's also maybe going to set
the
tone for how they handle gen shaw even
though this is tom's crime
right versus gen shaw's crying which is
so different
it is different but again these are both
crimes in which they're taking advantage
of
some of the most vulnerable people in
our society well another thing i noticed
about the trailer was like a huge
absence of garcelle um and i was even
wondering like when she got the job
at the real like if she was gonna be
able to do both because you film beverly
hills every day you film the reel every
day like
it's just a lot for one person and it
does feel like she's kind of slipping
through the narrative a little bit
because she wasn't even like a part of
like any major
like fights in the trailer yeah so it's
just a trailer but
yeah maybe like she's not part of the
big fight right it also felt like lisa
rena wasn't a big part of it that's true
but baby it's just like trailer there's
also just a lot of them now because
technically we have three new housewives
this season
kathy crystal and sutton sutton because
last year sutton wasn't a full-time
so it's just like a lot of women which
is good yeah because sometimes there are
some seasons of certain shows where like
there's literally four of them standing
holding the apple and it's like so
pathetic
yeah no it looks really really good when
does it premiere did it say
oh i don't know huh i'm very excited
like
wednesday may 19th that isn't so long
even though like what's the point in
even giving us the trailer
soon it will be may 19th but that just
feels like it's in so long i've just got
to get my usual wines ordered so that i
can watch the beverly hills trail uh
premiere peacefully with my perfect
glass of wine that sounds like heaven
cultivate that vibe with these
usual wines usual wines are wines for
the modern drinker each bottle is 6.3
ounces
so it's a heavy pour or about a glass
and a half of wine there's no more
pouring wine down the sink when you
don't finish the bottle
because of the single surf format and
bottle design usual is always fresh
you'll have no more flat bubbly or stale
rose the usual wines are low carb and
they have zero grams of sugar
they have a red blend a rose and a
sparkling white wine called root
they also have usual spritz a low
alcohol
a low alcohol low calorie wine spritzer
that's just made of sparkling wine and
guava juice
it's like a white cloth for grown ups
each of them have just 83 calories
if you want to check out their website
usualwines.com you can use promo code
toast for eight dollars off your first
order
and try your first glass on us usual
wines is the perfect way to unwind and
it really does solve like the universal
problem of like
not wanting to open another bottle but
like needing another glass and having
like one glass of wine is just like not
enough
so 6.3 ounces is everything of the sort
and you should check out usualwines.com
and make sure to use the promo code
toast for eight dollars off your first
order so you can try your first glass on
us all of the wines are made in avas
like uh napa sonoma and santa barbara
and they are made with minimal
intervention
zero sugar and zero additives that's
usualwines.com
promo code toast love it okay now we
have some
new relationship news casey musgraves
cozies up to her rumored new boyfriend
dr gerald anuoha it looks like casey
muskraves has found love again the
singer was spotted cozying up to her
rumored new boyfriend
in pictures exclusively obtained by page
six and then posted to the morning to
his instagram
while it is unclear whether musgraves
and dr gerald are officially dating the
pair were spotted embracing in l.a on
sunday as they waited for an
uber um the celebrities are just like us
the grammy winner kept alert casual with
a blue striped track suit and bell
bottom pants while dr gerald wore a
canadian tuxedo for the occasion
so then she posted on her instagram
story a selfie of the two of them
she did thus i think getting out and
confirming
yeah they're definitely official there's
the selfie oh so so stunning
so like i don't know who this man is but
i'm
so happy for casey musgraves like she's
just you know been through it
love wise yes he is a doctor at the hca
healthcare in nashville
he practices internal medicine according
to his linkedin page
we absolutely love a doctor daddy you
know what i love doctor
you know what i love what i love when a
celebrity dates someone and in order to
find out information about them we have
to go to linkedin wholesome
no like real person yep job with a job
just like
henry cavill's girlfriend yesterday wait
literally casey muskegee's new boyfriend
is boy with a job
yeah well he's a doctor actually he's
doctor for chemin with a job
i'm so happy for her these pictures were
so cute um
he lives in nashville which is so great
i wonder if they just like met out at a
restaurant like
how does the it's so rare when a
celebrity dates like a civilian
how do they meet maybe she went to see
him for like you know
a problem maybe or maybe she was like in
the hospital
for a you know a personal reason or
maybe she was visiting
some people singing songs for them to go
to hospitals like
who knows maybe they met on a dating app
for young professionals
yeah young professionals in the national
area yeah i'm just so happy for her that
she
seems to be in love yeah i mean i was
hoping for her to like date someone
famous because like i just love when
celebrities date other celebrities
but also i'm such a big casey man like i
truly just want her to be happy and it
looks like she's
found just that yeah truly truly does so
all aboard on the ship no no
what sound does a boat make yeah
um speaking of another couple that you
might have forgotten about
macaulay culkin and brenda song welcome
a bebe i could never forget about them
like ever
macaulay culkin and girlfriend brenda
song are parents the couple welcomed
their first child together
son dakota song culkin on april 5th in
la where overjoyed the couple said in a
statement
named after his um late sister who just
passed away
oh that's so beautiful yeah a lot of
people like no don't even know that
these two are dating like the kid from
home alone and london tipton
and i'm not gonna lie i didn't know
either until i was faced with such a
harsh reality
me and ben went to wwe summerslam at
barclays center like
three years ago and we had gotten like
these fancy like passes and we were like
shuffled in through the back and it was
like this vip room for like you know
celebrities like us
and macaulay culkin and brenda song were
in there me and ben were like
that is home alone and that is london
tempted and they were like holding hands
the whole time and they had this like
posse
and me and ben were like are they dating
and ever since then like i've known that
they're dating but like most people do
not know this fun fact because they're
very private no and i also feel like
every
you know few years there's a story about
them in the news they're spotted out and
so you remember and then you forget
again
and then the next story comes up and
it's like oh my god they're dating like
i did know that but i forgot it no one
like in my mind i'm still living in like
2009 when like brenda song was dating
trey cyrus
and macaulay culkin was eating mila
kunis yes like that's where
i'm just kind of like living permanently
and i'm not really upset about it either
yeah well that's why every time there's
news about these two it's like
it's like the first time it feels like
the first
time i have a bruise like in my
middle finger like it's not a bruise
it's like a pain and probably like you
have a bruiser
it's probably an issue like a vocal
tendonitis maybe it's tendonitis and it
like always hurts my
middle finger and i just snapped and it
hurt you know what
i had such one time i had such a bad
case of tendonitis i thought that i
might have gout because it happens in
like your limb like your thumbs and toes
right
yeah toe oh well then never mind i went
to the doctor
my right thumb it was pain i was like
it's carpal tunnel
no it wasn't i was like i could
literally die from this it was
tendinitis
i put it in a s slint what's it called
splint
thank you i put it in a splint
and i slept with it for one night and
literally the next morning it was
crazy like how a little piece of metal
can change your life get a splint from
dwayne reed like it will really change
your life okay but what do you think
it's from like why
now why this finger i just like i
wouldn't worry about like the the cause
i would just worry about the treatment
like get yourself a split okay but like
if you don't know what happened you're
bound to keep letting it happen but if
you could just keep fixing it like why
does it matter
no i think that you need to know the
cause i mean you you need to know where
i went to like a fancy hand doctor if
you want his number and he diagnosed me
with tendonitis
no i mean i'll try to split i'm really
not in the mood to like deal with it but
it's just like it's [ __ ] weird no you
can literally buy a splinter dwayne read
and it's
like medical grade and it was so
life-changing i can't
praise the splint community enough no
and i know that someone's gonna like let
me know
what you have yeah right so thank you to
dr toasters
and congratulations to macaulay culkin
and uh
we'd love to see it now our fifth and
final story some really exciting news
that you already knew but
i'm hearing it for the first time
hurting my finger while it snaps
i'll get the snaps okay should i keep
singing i think it's okay
okay maybe later powerpuff girls
live action in cw pilot's first look so
the powerpuff girls are coming to tv
live action starring dove cameron as
bubbles
chloe bennett as blossom and jana
peralta as buttercup
i think this is so exciting yeah i like
never really got into powerpuff girls
like watching it as a television show
you know yeah no we didn't really watch
powerpuff
girls but i just i like shaded the
aesthetic i appreciate the aesthetic
like i like the vibes and now they make
for some really funny memes
yeah no i remember that yeah
so i'm really excited about this and
again i probably won't watch um
like everything else that we report on
that i'm really excited about yeah um
let's talk let's talk about the cw for a
minute you know okay let's talk about it
they've had such like interesting phases
like i feel like when we were
younger first of all the cw used to be
the wb correct
yeah and that was like buffy the vampire
like sort of because with cw 11 from
wb11 i don't think it's like a rebrand i
think it's like they took over the
channel
okay that's literally a rebrand
it was wb and upn and then they emerged
called cw
oh i guess that makes cw was so amazing
you know i feel like they have like
really good years you know like when
riverdale first debuted like they were
like killing it and now like i cannot
believe riverdale is still on like what
are those kids doing in vancouver no the
cw is still doing well i gossip girl
90210 like we're all on when on the cw
when we were in high school i'm like
that was like the channel to be
now for me it's like i immediately go to
bravo but like when i was a kid i would
immediately go to cw
because like you're an older woman now
and the kids i think are
yeah i said it did you just yep i did
and the kids
are still going to cw i think and i know
you don't watch riverdale anymore but do
you a lot of people do
i i watch at the end of each season like
i'll spend a day binging it because i
can't deal with the cliffhangers of like
yeah
silliness yeah but i think that the cw
is in a good season right now i think
powerpuff girls will be
a great addition also um everyone keeps
telling me to watch the show
rain which is a cw show based on like
the story of mary queen of scots but
it's like
drama gossip girl oh you know that like
that like kind of
like cheap yes yeah so i don't know if
i'm gonna watch it but
literally so many people have told me
too so maybe i will um
also the cwc which is where they host
all the old shows
is also a really good platform what is
it called cw seed
i recently released an app yeah i
rewatched privilege on it
and it was so [ __ ] good was it so
[ __ ] good i love joanna swisher
so [ __ ] good if you have cwc which i
think it's free i had to watch
commercials
um treat yourself one season it ends on
a cliffhanger
i know but um i would also rewatch 90210
like
the shailene you know what i'm not
shaylene woodley
she grinds yes it wasn't it was good
when it was on
but it wasn't even that good not good
enough to watch again
okay but like i think it's worth
rewatching just to see sarah foster play
naomi's sister jen i know and like naomi
put the show on her back
naomi put the [ __ ] show on her
[ __ ] back justice for adeline
mccord and i can't
like the show was meh really but like it
came at a good time and it was like good
vibes whatever
but like the amount of anxiety i had
when um
annie killed a man oh then she had to
like it was turned out to be like
jasper's
dad dad like i shouldered so much of
that anxiety for her
like living your life going to school
like knowing that you know
and so like i just don't want to go back
that was a really dark storyline like
she was so upset about something and
she's driving tell anyone
and like it was just horrible and then
the only person she like found solace in
was jasper and then like when she found
out that like it was literally his dad
that she [ __ ] killed like that was
horrible it was too much for the kids
no you're right i actually remember that
that was so dark
it was so dark i just like i feel like
we all
shouldered that yeah and then like there
was just like so much going on with like
dixon and meghan markle like there was
just like a lot going on there was a lot
going on there was a lot going on with
adriana
oh my god i forgot about her and then
she went to hallmark
she's literally like the prettiest girl
ever what's her name
so there's a lot going on and i don't
want to go back there yeah no i feel
that 100 but good good good to know
about cwc
like you can get in the app store yeah
and they have so many shows like shows
that probably weren't even on the cw but
like rcw vibes
love that yeah um i have a little
kelly's mindless news if you
don't mind i mean i never mind i mean
it's it's
breaking mindless news hit me well it's
brought to you by pros
there's no one-size-fits-all when it
comes to your shampoo and conditioner
we need products that are suited for our
unique needs and don't leave us
disappointed
thanks to our personalized pros shampoo
and conditioner we have fall in love
with our hair again
pros knows there is more than to you
there's more to you than just your hair
type
pros has given over one million
consultations with their in-depth hair
quiz which is how we got started
so we love a quiz over here it makes us
feel so seen and it really like
it's true like not everyone has the same
hair needs my hair gets like really dry
it's super textured it's very thick and
humid so like ever i shouldn't be having
the same shampoo as you
100 the quiz is so in-depth they really
get to the root of what you need yeah
they like even ask you what your eating
habits are because they can all affect
your hair
like what kind of city you live in
environmental factors like it's so long
with it and then they also ask you like
what you want to gain from a shampoo
like do you want something
with a smell what kind of smell i
literally got my pros
shampoo conditioner and pre shampoo mask
and it's so amazing i feel like my hair
has been super shiny yeah it has and i
just i love pros
so with their algorithm there are over
50 billion formula combinations pros has
determined a unique blend of ingredients
to treat our exact concerns
and if you're not 100 positive it pros
is the best hair care you've had they
will take the products back and no
questions asked
pros is the healthy hair regimen with
your name all over it take your free
in-depth hair quiz and get 15 off your
first order today
go to pros.com toast that's p r
o s e dot com slash toast for your free
in-depth hair quiz and 15
off so today's uh kelly's
today's kelly's mindless news like the
4th of july
kelly's mindless news is a party segment
this is no way affiliated with cali
rippo or her family friends and anyone
associated with calorie ripper we
apologize in advance for any offense we
may cause
um it's from a new outlet
usually we pick up from hello magazine
which is like a british tabloid that
like literally would write about like
the color of
kelly ripa's couch like they've
literally done that but today
we have something from more reputable
site which is really disappointing
purewow live with kelly and ryan
made a major change to the morning show
this week
okay kelly brown i love morning show
change news no and it's
major wow okay kelly ripa and ryan
seacrest are welcoming a brand new
member to the live with kelly and ryan
team
this week the co-hosting duo introduced
their new
announcer for the morning show media
personality and radio
host deja vu on thursday and friday
friday the producers of live
shared behind the scenes clips featuring
the new announcer introducing the
episodes of the show
after she revealed the date she stated
and now here are kelly ripa
and ryan seacrest during today's
backstage footage the 50 year old
television personality and her 45 year
old co-host opened up about how excited
they were for deja vu to join the team
it's so much fun watching you say our
names because i know it's our
cue seacrest said in the clip before
ripa added
as you know change happens glacially
around here so i'm excited
so it's major major [ __ ] news that
they have a new announcer
new announcer and like literally when
she says kelly's name that's when ryan
knows
they're cute and it's just so
interesting to see how tv works you know
someone announces and you know i
wouldn't necessarily think like
here's kelly and ryan means that kelly
and ryan are coming
but thanks to this article i now know
that once deja vu says
kelly ripa and ryan seacrest that means
that the show begins
it's really it's magic how they make
those things work like
it's rocket science no it's so
like so cool of pureroute to kind of
give us like a behind the scenes
no it's like look at how like the sauce
gets made a hundred percent it's movie
magic
it's brilliant and i'm just so grateful
to not only purewow but the kelly's
mindless new segment for teaching me
like things about the tv world that i
didn't know
maybe like we could implement some of
those learnings at our morning show like
maybe if someone announced us like we
would know it was time right and like
maybe if someone announced us like we
would know it's
our show and like that's all she wrote
and that it's no one else's and pencils
down yeah so i don't know i just thought
like that was a really interesting piece
of kind of like television news and
something i feel like i couldn't go on
with my day without really kind of
examining no and nor
could the toasters i don't think that
they could have gone on with their day
and that's the point of this show it's
like two the news you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toes and there's
literally no [ __ ] doubt in my entire
mind that like you did not need to know
this
you didn't need to know you did need to
know this sorry yes i agree
i feel inspired like i'm ready to take
on the day
ww krd what would kelly ripa do
she would do something mindless and then
have an article written about it
that's what she do and you know what we
have no choice but to respect the craft
responsible relevancy for 50 years for
50 years
and again we just can't stress enough
kelly's mindless news has absolutely
nothing to do with keller is in no way
affiliated with kelly or any members of
her family friend or
morning show yeah no i mean i think a
lot of people probably thought like it
was like sponsored by
live with kelly and ryan but right
because we give them something was
actually on live with kelly and ryan
this morning oh my god what was he
talking you know spring travel tips like
traveling in the pandemic any tips that
we need to know about
um i mean the number one tip from
the points guy that like really changed
my life is like once you accrue points
like from a credit card
do not use the portal like from the
credit card from chase.com like or like
transfer it to the hotel partner to the
airline partner they're more valuable
that way
so i'm sure there's more to it but that
was like kind of the one big takeaway
that is an interesting takeaway also
something that's interesting this next
time you see us
merch will be live at
shopmorningtoast.com 10 am tomorrow
tomorrow 100 collection you 100
need to get it so here's what we have we
have the three phone cases
well there will be pictures on our
instagram the morning toast um
today so you'll see all the products but
we have three phone cases jackie's
wearing the pink one
i have the black one and then there's
also like a teal that matches my
sweatshirt
my outfit right now is a set it has
pants that's a hundred percent on the
leg
it's teal it has pockets i love this one
i'm wearing it in an extra large and the
one i wore
yesterday was the black set in an extra
large no pockets in that one the green
one has the pockets yes and then this
pink sweater is a standalone item
no pants and it's just like the cutest
thing to
for your spring wardrobe and we have
mugs and these are the big mugs like i
think from now on we fully transitioned
all of our mugs to be the big ass mugs
because people loved the redheads one i
love a big ass mug and i feel so
strongly that all of our mugs
go for skill should be a big ass mug
yeah this is a bam because you don't
have to worry about like things spilling
like you just like to have
more than enough space in your mug and
fun fact nearly an entire can of diet
coke fits in here because that's what's
in here that is extremely fun and then
we also have our dad baseball cap
says 100 sickening the scalp down it's
black it's everything of the sort like
if you're a runner
she's a runner she's oh we need to talk
about my tick tock time limit yesterday
i put it on for an hour and at 5 30 i
hit my limit
and it was really good i did go back on
twice
for a few minutes so i ended up at an
hour and 20 minutes which is very good
for me that is very good
and um it's still on today but last
night i couldn't sleep and so at like 12
i was on tick tock for like 20 minutes
so i'm already at 20 minutes this
morning and i haven't even been on it
since i woke up
well that's just something you need to
consider i did spend more time on other
platforms like instagram and twitter but
i do think like i was more productive
yesterday because like
i like it definitely helps like i
recommend it and for everyone asking how
to do it just go to your screen time app
and you can set limits for any app
i think it's great yes like you went to
reels and twitter but like those places
are more boring and so
eventually i spent less time you'll be
left with with nothing else to look at
and maybe you'll get off your phone
i just feel like today i didn't have
that much to offer to the show because
like all of my interesting factoids like
i literally get from tiktok
well maybe if you start being more
intentional with your time on tick tock
they'll start serving you
like the best premium that's creme de la
creme which means cream i know some of
you guys are from new jersey
i love jackie what's my comedy special
available is a stream on amazon prime
for free it's called disgrace queen and
it's actually free so
enjoy enjoy um i do believe
that's all right yeah i believe as well
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so it's
spotify i choose stitcher public radio i
heart radio cast box
all the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us morning toast leave a
five star review about how beautiful
stunning
and smart we are we hope you guys have
an amazing day we'll see you tomorrow
for hump day and for the merch drop so
don't miss out shopmorningtoast.com at
10 a.m eastern time
tomorrow see ya goodbye